there is that left-hander alex wood
pitching for the san francisco giants
broke into the league in 2013.
astro fans will remember him with that
world series team of the la dodgers in
2017 on the season 365 era 229 banning
average against 67 degrees at game time
on the ground to short crawford right
there
and he throws out altuve
it's that one on the ground and flores
cuts across in front of crawford two
down
you're playing on the left side of the
infield with
all these right-handers hitting against
alex wood you're going to get a lot of
work 1-1
and that's lifted shallow left center
field and that's going to drop in for a
base hit just past crawford and in front
of wade so michael brantley with his
fourth hit in the last two days and all
of them have been singles it gives julie
guriel a chance guerrielle having
another big year 317 average 11 home
runs one and one to go real right-handed
hitter and the pitch a line drive right
to flores at third he
just clobbered another one so he
hit a couple of liners here in
consecutive pitches and some real bad
luck one just went foul the other one
went right to florence in this ballpark
right here he is undefeated with a 6-0
record in a 1.19 era as you drink in his
numbers for the season
loves pitching in this ballpark as he
faces the giants with a couple of
lefties at the top another 3-2
swing and a miss
struck him out on a slider and that is
the second out of the inning first
strikeout for grinky on the afternoon
there's darren ruff two-two
strike three call at the knees ruff
thought it was a little low and he has a
legitimate beef with brian o'norah
as he has something to say before he
goes back to the dugout but a one two
three first for grinke donovan solano
with two down and nobody on he delivers
there's a high drive deep to left
way back there on its way
[Music]
into the bleachers in straight away left
and out of here with plenty to spare to
give the giants a one-nothing lead i
think that solano went up there looking
for exactly what he got he's looking for
a curveball and that front foot is tied
to the off-speed pitch and there's a
little height in that that breaker
absolutely unloads into it perfect
timing the other way you get that is if
you're looking for that speed one one
pitch there's a hard ground ball lunging
for it into the hole it's short is
correa he gets the glove on it slows it
up and then races out after it into left
field to
try and make sure that duggar with his
great speed doesn't try for second kurt
casalli
a liner and a fair ball just inside the
line duggars gonna come fly into third
and he'll get the stop sign there the
karum was a gentle one
and that keeps the giants from scoring
another run that's big and i think so
alex wood comes to the plate he is
over 28 this year without an rbi the 2-2
that is strike 3 call at the knees got
him with the fastball wood goes down
looking and the inning is over giants
get a run on the home run by solano they
strand a couple bring up a led miss diaz
who grounded out the third base his
first time up the o2 and diaz hits this
well and deep to left racing back his
weight looking up and that ball is gone
olette means diaz homers for the second
straight day and the astros lead it 2-1
diaz his fifth of the year
fouls that ball off his foot get that
soft front side keep the weight back and
you get it off speed pitch and hammer it
looked like they were trying to get that
slider to that inside corner and it
stays out over the plate
yuli goes the other way and gets one
pass the second baseman solano in the
right field so this inning will continue
yulia guriel's hit the ball hard twice
now has a hit to show for it now it's
correa he flied out to deep left his
first time
correa chops one towards third third
baseman flores will make the throw it's
a wide throw and high throw and the
astros will get a run out of it routine
ground ball that flores throws away and
the astros lead three to one
the giants are just falling apart here
all of a sudden defensively i wonder how
much of a distraction it was with the
runner cutting in front of floors there
at the end of that play now the 1-2
pitch
swing and a roller towards short nobody
was right correa drops it the third
baseman diaz cut over in front of him
but did not
field the ball and correa might have
been screened out at the last moment so
here is wilmer flores runner at first
two down in the inning rough goes again
wilmer high drive down the left field
line
toward the corner it is gone a fair ball
and wilbur flores makes up for that
error ties the game with one swing
and after the two-out error by correa
the giants capitalize and put two on the
board that's exactly what he went up
there to try and do and he does it in a
two-out two-strike situation
1-1 pitch up the middle on the ground
crawford far to his left has it spins
around throws to first he got him what a
play brandon crawford
amazing off the bat i thought no chance
even for the
gold glover brandon crawford getting
fully extended to his left now how's he
going to get rid of it 360s unloads the
gun
and it's a strike and a nice stretch for
rough to gather it in two down here's
lamont wade junior there goes casalli
that ball is hit a mile to right
headed for san francisco bay
it is white
five to three giants lamont way junior
well we talked about how big this
situation was and they're in a 3-2 count
he puts a just a lazy fastball middle in
and lamont wade stays inside it knocks
it in the pond 108 miles per hour
mother emily oh that's great led missed
with home runs in back-to-back games now
five on the year
that ball's hit high and hit deep oled
miss diaz three home runs and four at
bats he makes it a one-run game
oled miss diaz
another
multi-hit game today with two home runs
in the mix center cut and unloaded on i
think alex wood knew it before oled miss
diaz did uriel waiting for a 2-2
brandley off first pitch on the way and
yuli hits it hard and under the glove of
estrada and it goes all the way into
left field all the way to the wall
chugging for third base is brantley he's
around third and coming home there will
be no throw to the plate it's an rbi
double for yuli and the astros have tied
it at five
a lot of offense today five runs on each
side both teams with six hits errors
haven't helped either
that one is hit high and deep to left
field
headed for berkeley goodbye
and the giants jump back ahead
six to five darren ruff that one just
exploded off his back that is the fourth
home run already for the giants today in
five innings against grenkey two away
now it's maldonado jackson delivers and
maldonado cranks one deep to left field
back goes wade at the wall and we're
tied
martine maldonado goes deep for the
eighth time this year
six six ball game there's the hang and
there's the bang two consecutive two odd
hits here for the giants
line drive right center base hit rough
in to score the giants are back ahead
estrada speeds around to third matt
crawford hit a liner that was just
barely foul next pitch another line
drive that was fair
seven to six giants so here is your
scramski to lead off against the
right-hander yastrepski high drive right
field this one is gone mike istrebski go
fishing 17th of the year for yaz
411th
feet and it's eight to six giants
he hits a high fly ball left field
slater
back on the track squares up ball game
over and the giants beat the astros to
even up the series and set up the rubber
match tomorrow